hi my name is Ida Salome and managing
partner to phone communications here in
Idaho I wanna first start off by saying
welcome to Idaho this was a great time a
great event and I know there's gonna be
Theo Pia before the world economy forum
and it definitely will be another here
but after that world economy for regards
to the question and the statement about
African youth being empowered within the
next year I think one of the key things
is to unleash the creativity of rapper
can use them in order for that to happen
it doesn't take government alone it
takes families it takes neighbors it
takes teachers it takes friends it takes
everybody to encourage and empower
African youth to first of all believe in
themselves but live in the communities
believe in the country believe in the
government and that alone will be a huge
commercial change I think that happens
when when we unleash the potential and
and the energy of youth thank you very
much